so I'm gonna talk to you this morning
about something that's fantastic about
the human brain its capacity to change
and part it must change as we go from
being an infant to a child to an
adolescent to a young adult as we go
through adulthood from young adulthood
to middle adulthood to senior adulthood
changes you know every moment of our
life it has to change when we learn
something it has to change when we feel
something so the brain's capacity to
change to be physically plastic is you
know one of the most amazing properties
of our minds engine and so I'd like to
think about the fragile power of the
human brain so this is that mysterious
you know two pound three pound object
right that lets us see and hear move our
hands feel the world learn to read
mathematics music to love you know just
everything that we have as a human
capacity every moment we live is endowed
by neurons firing and organized patterns
and I've been blessed and well you know
work on that is missing my career since
I was a graduate student here and in
this fantastic environment at MIT in the
McGovern Institute but for every
strength an astounding strength I mean
that's what neuroscientists are trying
to figure out how does the brain do it
it doesn't seem like it should be able
to do it okay if we knew the answers to
that we closed the Institute so I don't
want scare Karen okay we'd say you know
mission accomplished but we are so far
from understanding how the brain in the
human really works we know many more
things than we did a decade ago but
we're very far from really understanding
any complete story but we do know that
for every fantastic strength of the
brain there's an Achilles heel if we can
anticipate the future we can be anxious
about the future if we can have feelings
we can be depressed if we can have
thoughts we can thought disorders of
schizophrenia if we can learn to read
and reading is an unbelievably powerful
cultural invention we can have dyslexia
if we can pay attention and focus our
thoughts a child can have ADHD so for
practically every fantastic power of the
human brain there's a risk or an
Achilles heel right and so it's our job
both to understand how the brain does
the marvelous things it does and when it
goes astray what can we understand about
that that might be informative for
helping people lead happier healthier
lives
so in a very simple way how do we know
how the brain works and there's many
levels of study of the brain in this
building from molecules to neurons and
things like that I'm gonna focus on
humans and sort of you know big brain
areas and from that most of our
knowledge up until about 15 or 20 years
ago came from brain injuries or brain
lesions so you have been exposed
probably the story of Phineas Gage in
Vermont who had a huge shaft explode
through the lower portions of his
inferior frontal cortex and shoot out
about 50 yards away
it was huge an explosion and a workplace
explosion and the remarkable thing and
here's his actual brain here's the
actual exit of that large rod exploded
from a railroad construction and the
remarkable thing about him was first at
the time they were just impressed that
he lived that was the story he went back
to his hotel room he kind of had a
headache and they said wow he lived but
but the lesson for history which has
been supported by a lot of research
since then is that he changed his
character that this part of the brain
seems to be involved in assigning value
to things what's matters what's the
right thing to do what's a bad thing to
do and that once you have this part of
the brain be injured in his case is
character change he went from being a
very model employee and citizen to being
a person who couldn't hold a job at
fantastic and irresponsible plans
mislead all his family members and
friends about what he was up to from
this day forward okay so so character or
here's the left hemisphere of rotation
named tan this is actual preserved brain
who had an injury here at that time they
had no brain imaging they had to wait
until he passed away to see where the
injury was but based on his behavior
Paul Broca the neurologist figured out
this is a part of the brain in the left
frontal area that's important for the
production of language and in fact I've
learned from a neurologist and
neuroscientist this nice phrase the
eloquent cortex the cortex that allows
us to speak and comprehend that in
almost all of us is in the left
hemisphere and so that's how we learned
about language and the hemispheric
specialization in the brain and when I
was a graduate a student at MIT I had
the amazing opportunity to work with
arguably the most famous neurological
patient of the 20th century a man whose
initials are HM he's the man whom the
1950s had a very
small surgery removing these small
structures in the insides of his
temporal lobes that's his actual MRI
this is the neurosurgeons cartoon of the
neuro surgical resection to treat
epilepsy but unknown at the time if you
remove the hippocampus and adjacent
structures on the left and the right
both sides you lose the ability to form
a new memory ever again so this was a
man of normal intelligence and normal
pretty normal life and then retained all
of that in fact his IQ score went up
after a surgery probably because the
medications he was taking we're
dampening it a bit but he could never
form a new memory again from that day
till a couple of years ago when he
passed away and he taught us that these
parts of the brain are essential for
forming new memories for the events we
experience in our lives or for the fact
that we accounter during those
experiences so this is a way that we've
been learned about the human brain and
one limitation is you know you have to
wait until there's a neurological
tragedy to learn something right and so
there's huge ranges of human experience
like changes we have through this
lifespan from infancy to adulthood that
we can't investigate systematically that
way but for about the last 15 years
you've seen the revolution in imaging
the capacity to non-invasively image
aspects of the structure of the brain
and the function of the brain and
investigate how that works in people in
good health and and not in good health
and so downstairs we have an Imaging
Center I think that's one of your tour
options this morning that has an MRI to
look and I'll show you but a bit more
about these things to look at structure
and function we can measure a diffusion
tensor imaging I'll tell you what that
is other kinds of devices that measure
brains operating at the millisecond
speed of thought neurons fire and
thousands of a second and accomplished
thinking and thousands of a second and
so we have a fantastic environment in
which to understand better both a
healthy brain and then difficulties in
brain function so here's a typical brain
scanner that's downstairs 3 Tesla it's a
research ones extra-strong manic to give
us extra good pictures here's the kind
of picture that comes out of there so
here's your brainstem going down to let
you move your body your cerebellum
here's the white matter
that's the myelin covering of neurons
that communicate with one another
and here's the corpus callosum that
connects the left and right hemispheres
here's a nice picture that's gonna whiz
through an individual human brain from
one year through to the other ear
and so now we don't have to wait for the
rare patient with a rare injury right we
can look in everybody's brain and so
they'll take one discovery at the
beginning of the lifespan early in
childhood which is this and some of you
may know this but let me just it's a
kind of an amazing story
so um the way the brain grows and you
may know this is this if you were to
build a building and you want a nice
two-story building for some reason nice
two-story house here's what you probably
wouldn't do you probably wouldn't build
a 50 story skyscraper stand back and
knock off the top 48 stories to end up
with your two-story house right you've
considered that wasteful you so like
that'd be like the worst plan you've
ever heard right but that's almost
exactly what your brain and that of
family members and humans have done
forever we have we make many more
neurons than we keep we make many more
connections between those neurons that
we keep and pretty much a lot of the
lifespan from age 5 to 20 is shedding
neurons and shedding connections among
neurons that are not serving the best
purpose and keeping those ones that
through education and experience are
really powerful neurons computing
helpful things and so what happens quite
stunningly is the neocortex are six
layers of the neurons that are kind of
our smarts of the brain become thinner
from childhood through adult so young
adulthood because you're getting rid of
the neurons that aren't doing a good job
so here using this kind of imaging is
this picture so dark means thinner and
look at this from five to twenty you can
see the brain is getting cortex is
getting thinner and thinner as these
children moved from being a
five-year-old right to a college student
and here's a video that will show from
NIH researchers just in a couple of
seconds you know
the entire lifespan until you are in the
middle of college almost here we go
okay now you're ready to vote okay it's
kind of a nice kind of a stunning story
and we get these from these structural
pictures in children whom we could never
have begun to think about these stories
you know with waiting for the rare brain
injury and we can also see an example of
change in the brain here's a fun study
from some years ago where undergraduates
were taught to learn how to juggle okay
these were non jugglers and for about a
month
every day they juggled for about half an
hour and they looked at their brains
before and after and asked using this
kind of imaging because they see
physical changes in the brain that were
associated with this newly learned skill
and what you see here in yellow are
parts of the brain that grew by the way
it can be measured as a consequence of
this skill and it's kind of cool to see
that but we know that everything you
learn and every fact you remember and
every skill you get has to go with the
physical change in the brain the
physical change in the brain is the
stuff of learning and memory and change
so it's a it's just that we weren't able
to see it before in a healthy person
immersing the skill by the way you might
wonder when they stop juggling because
it pretty much most of these people
decided they didn't want to do it after
the month and they were imaged a few
months later it went back to how it was
before so so this is what you know
health clubs make all their money in
January services this is the year you
know but we all know that we can't
exercise in January call it a year and
you know have been in top shape right
prayer beyond right you know you have to
keep going so the brain can go both
directions positively and it can it can
relax too much so this is brain
structure this is physical Anatomy but
an amazing discovery in the 1990s allow
us to look at brain function in the same
safe non-invasive way and I'll just say
a word about the method so you see both
its strengths and its limitations so
this is functional MRI which we will
allow us and I'll show you some pictures
to see human thoughts and feelings
flicker across the brain and what we
measure directly are not the neurons
that compute the mind where we gossip we
interview the gossipy neighbors the
blood that supports it so the blood
carries hemoglobin that provides oxygen
to neurons and neurons like all cells in
the body
need oxygen to live and so what happens
when neurons are active is the brain
sends you know the all the time
hemoglobins you sent through the
capillaries and it's being extracted to
support the neurons when a part of the
brain becomes active two things happen
for a brief moment there are there's a
lot of oxygen is extracted and this area
becomes reduced in oxygen we can't
measure that very well we can't measure
the second thing that happens which is
the brain over supplies oxygen to that
part of the brain it's as if it we're
saying you know this partner Bay is
working hard we better send a lot of
resources there and that we can measure
that change in oxygenation that's what
we're really measuring so that means
functional MRI is very related to which
part of the brain is is is active but
it's not really looking at the neurons
that are computing the mind but we can
see amazing things and this is I work
from Adrian Owen some years ago that
there was really striking and I made the
cover that you know front page of the
New York Times and he looked at a
patient who emerged from a coma who
appeared to be awake she was in a
vegetative state but had no sign of
awareness he was 23 years old and a
traffic accident five months later was
just unresponsive but she had preserved
sleep we could wake cycles so they took
this unresponsive vegetative coma
patient and they put her into the
scanner and then he asked them to do two
different things one of them is to
imagine playing tennis and one of them
is to imagine walking around the rooms
in our house starting with their front
door now there's a lot of research
they're shown that imagination is
perception run backwards when you
imagine the face of somebody you know
you turn on the parts of your brain that
are specialized with seeing faces if I
imagine moving my arm I will turn on
parts of my motor system that normally
move my arm okay so how do we imagine
things we use the parts of the brain
that do those things so now here's this
patient in the scanner and she's asked
so let me show - imagine playing tennis
this is part of the brain this
supplementary motor area that helps us
organize our movements and look
at--that's turn on just like it is in
typical healthy people
so this they didn't even know if the
patient understood the instruction okay
or even heard them particularly but not
only did she hear them she imagined
playing tennis and the brain image spoke
for her because she could not speak for
herself and then just to make sure it
was not random
here's imagining going around your house
and what people typically do is to turn
on parts of the brain that are involved
in spatial navigation learning how to
get around a space but I get around MIT
or your house or your community and here
she is in the scanner and now she turns
on those areas so she's not able to
speak but her brain can speak for itself
through functional imaging after this
was done there was the thought that
maybe many many people in coma are full
of thoughts and can't express them and
it turned out that since then about 10
to 20 percent of patients have this
property even coma most don't you ask
them to imagine something nothing
happens but still now there's a recent
method for identifying which one has
original inter mental life and which one
might not so let me switch from a
completely other direction to reading so
reading is as you know the essence the
essential vehicle of Education you can't
even if you love math and science as we
do here at MIT you still have to read
the math look right and things like that
so the reading is the engine of
education in our society and yet about
15% of children really struggle to learn
how to read and they have what's called
dyslexia and we can do brain imaging and
ask can we see what's different than the
brain of a child for whom reading is a
fantastic challenge so this is our own
research I'm going to show you now but
one thing you might wonder is you know
how much does a child like being in an
MRI scanner now we have a bias sample
you know if a child doesn't want to go
get their brain imaged we don't see them
right or a parent doesn't want to but uh
but the ones who participate really are
enthusiastic we have a great time with
them so here's a spontaneous know we got
some years ago buzz-buzz that's can I do
that again the nice cartoon from this
girl nine-year-old girl she said you've
let me had more fun in three days and I
could have in any other place just think
of it I'm playing a game when at the
same time I'm a research guinea pig okay
she gets one point off her spelling and
who knows and who knows I might help
someone this is a beautiful though else
my age if they have brain problems while
still earning money and what do you
think beats that nothing right it's a
beaut it's the beautiful sincere message
of a child and the money they get is
tiny okay so it's fantastic so we can't
I can tell you the children have a very
positive experience to go through these
studies and here's what we did
in the scanner while they're laying
there and you saw them the video and
example of traveling and Skinner in one
condition they looked at pairs of
letters and they decide are these the
same or different so these are the same
these are different that's easy you
don't even have to know anything about
English or letters to answer that right
and the other condition they were asked
whether the names of these letters
rhymes so G and K don't rhyme T and D
and in the same Isan they do write what
we're making them do is think about
sounds associated with print and that
link between language sounds and print
is what's most commonly weak in children
who struggle to read and here's what we
see and it's a very striking brain
difference so this is front of the brain
back of the brain left and right these
are three slices going up the brain and
you can see that typical 10 year olds
when they're thinking about the sounds
of letters turn on something near
Broca's area in the front up through
several brain regions as you're thinking
about the sounds of letters they're the
constituents of language and reading the
dyslexic children fail to turn on this
brain region for this comparison and
this activation is also a little bit
different looking so here's the brain
difference and a fantastic thing about
brain imaging for dyslexia and for many
other brain differences or diseases is
that it's made it visible for us for
some diseases like a stroke structural
scans often aren't you know tell you
where the stroke is but for many things
from autism ADHD dyslexia schizophrenia
depression anxiety obsessive compulsive
disorder you can make a long long list
for all of those things you cannot put
up a structural image of a patient and
say aha this patient has depression or
this page right it there is no signal
like that so it's only through
functional imaging that were able to see
what's different in the brain of
somebody who's struggling with these
kinds of things but there's something
you know so that's that's helped us
understand a little bit of what's going
on now I'm gonna show you the same
picture again from the side now so these
are typical reading and children turning
these areas on same spots not turned on
in children and then these children who
are poor readers went through a reading
intervention program that helped me
become better readers it didn't make
them great readers but on average had
moved up the reading ability
and now they start to turn on these same
brain areas so we can see this capacity
for the brain to change with education
with behavioral intervention and it can
make us think about what are the kinds
of things we can do to help children
thrive who are dealt a bad hand in terms
of their capacities to do well in school
now I can tell you about one more really
cool brain measure that that's widely
used in the field now diffusion tensor
imaging you saw a picture I'll show you
again so this show let's just look at
white matter in the brain basically the
information superhighways of the brain
and we do that by measurement of water
at the level of microns so let me tell
you how that kind of works so here's a
cartoon of a neuron the kinds of cells
we have in our brain here's a cell body
here's the axon that sends out
information and communicates with an X
neuron so neurons can work together as
networks and support human thoughts and
actions
if the neurons are larger neuron it at
the scale the neuron it has to send the
information far away at in order for
that information to arrive quickly and
accurately these cells get covered with
a fatty substance called a myelin that's
the white matter of the brain and that
allows the brain to communicate quickly
and accurately over distances now if
you're a molecule of water and you're in
something like the cerebrospinal fluid
of the brain or some watery area you can
diffuse or go anywhere you want right
there's no physical barriers but if
you're a molecule of water and you're
near one of these myelinated axons those
are pretty big things to me that's like
if we're out walking and there's a tree
okay we have to walk around the tree
okay and so that water has to sort of
flow with the large axons because it
can't bounce into them right so it has
to go walk through the between the trees
until it can get into a free space again
that's the basis on which you get
pictures like these and you saw a
version of this I'll just show you one
more time so what are you seeing here is
the picture that comes out of tracking
in a living person in the scanner and
tracking these water molecules flow
diffusion and what's color-coded here
are the different fiber paths so if
they're going from front to back with
their BAE they're in green if they're
mostly going up and down in your brain
they're in blue and if they're mostly
going left to right there
red and so this is an individual
person's brain
and you can do this fantastic tracking
of those things
and some years ago with chocolate
Klingberg we found that if we look this
is the front of the brain back of the
brain the ears would be here that if we
looked in this area we saw that in
adults who are poor readers we saw sort
of a weaker organization of this white
matter then in adults who were good
readers and roughly speaking it was in
this arcuate fasciculus so this is a
white matter pathways is a real human
brain this is the cartoon that connects
the area back here Wernicke's area and
Broca's area the two language centers of
the brain so it's a really important
information highway for language now we
saw that brain difference in adults but
we didn't know if that brain difference
is a cause or a consequence of the
reading difficulties let me explain me
that for a moment okay so one of the
striking things about children who are
poor readers is not surprisingly they
don't like to read at home and one
thinks of the reading difficulty is a
problem in school and it can be but it's
accompanied by fantastic differences in
reading in free time so in a diary study
some researchers have shown that a child
who's a poor reader at school will read
in a year at home what a typically
reading child reads in a week okay I
totally get it if something is really
unpleasant for you at school the last
thing you're gonna do is go home you
know and read more right I mean who
would I so what's happening over time is
people who read a lot are making their
brain change to become great reading
brains and people who read as little as
possible because it's frustrating and
disappointing for them they are getting
further and further behind so when we
see those young adults and that white
matter difference in their brain are
they like the jugglers okay as they've
been practicing reading so much they
tuned up that part of the brain to be a
great reading brain or are we seeing
something that's the risk for becoming a
bad reader and the way we can address
that is a study that we're in the middle
of but I can show you one result which
is looking at kindergarteners in the
beginning of the kindergarten year so
we've been pushing imaging down to
younger and younger children because we
want to understand the roots of
difficulties with the hope of promoting
intervention before a child ever fails
what happens now is you know for every
developmental disorder you
wait for the child to fail right oh my
gosh you've got a th-th
oh my gosh you've got this Lexi and you
wait for the child to be miserable at
home in a school until everybody decides
you know and and and parents of course
are very sensitive and they're trying to
interact as early as possible but the
system waits so the question is can we
identify with brain imaging risks and
children before they ever fail that's
where we're at now with the hope to help
them before they ever fail so here's the
study it's a fantastic study that were
doing in collaboration with people at
Children's Hospital as well
the imaging all occurs downstairs here
we're out in about 30 kindergartens and
those schools are working with us that
they write home to the parents and about
80% of parents allow us to test their
children behaviorally in the schools and
the schools are really interesting mix
the way just played out their inner city
charter schools Catholic schools and
suburban district schools so we actually
have an incredible representation of
different children in these studies so
and we go out to these 30 schools and we
test every child for about half an hour
we give a report back to the parent and
the school that's what they get and then
we invite in a range of these children
to look at their brains if the parents
want to come in with their child so
we're up to nearly a thousand
kindergartners in the Boston area have
been evaluated this way we look at
what's different in the brains of
children who look like you who are good
or bad at skills that matter for reading
at the beginning kindergarteners so most
of them are non readers so this is
before reading failure could possibly
occur but we know some tasks that if you
do badly on that our language tasks
talking tasks that upset chance will be
a bad reader okay
so now we're going to look at these
white matter pathways through the fusion
tensor imaging in these children who are
kindergarteners or five-year-olds and
here's an initial finding so this is how
well they do in a language test this is
how big this arcuate fasciculus is that
connects language areas in the left
hemisphere and you can see them better
they do in the language test the bigger
the volume so in these pre readers
before they've ever had formal reading
instruction already the children with
the skills the language skills that go
with good reading look you can even see
this look at the size of that compared
to the size of that okay so that makes
us think that something about this white
matter organization
is a cause for being a good reader or a
bad reader but it also says maybe we
could do something to help this child
before he or she fails maybe we could
intervene selectively and supportively
and not wait for reading failure to
become a thing that was discouraging for
that child or family so we're very we
you know I feeling this amazing that
parents allow us and we're very grateful
it's very safe it's not a risk but still
it's an amazing thing for a parent to
bring in you know a four or five year
old for an imaging study and we're very
lucky to have this participation now
I'll say one word about reading from one
moment which is what functional MRI as
terrific as it is or diffusion tensor
imaging but I mean or they show you
structure which is consistent for a long
time or function with blood it's a slow
measure neurons are fast your brains are
fast neurons fire on the order of you
know 10 thousandths of a second a lot of
action happens in your mind very quickly
and so we have other kinds of measures
and there's maybe you'll see a machine
downstairs that we have one of them is
called magnetic encephalography or mu G
that measures from the outside it get in
safe and non-invasive tiny signals that
change in magnetic properties near the
skull because of neurons firing and this
we can do on the order of a millisecond
at a time so this is a nice work from
Eric Hogan his college showing you the
left hemisphere everything you're going
to see it takes less than a second
responding to seeing and reading a
single word
it's kind of beautiful isn't okay uh you
know yeah it's like a it's like a ballet
or having you know coming in going out
you know do it one more time I just
think it's so stunning okay that's a
brain seeing and sending information
back and forth back and forth what's
that word okay so these are the kinds of
pictures that make us you ever hear the
idea that we only use 10% of our brain
or something like that okay now we
probably know individuals you know who
we suspect really do that but yeah
neuroscientist or I do that sometimes
neuroscientists um you know when you see
a picture like that to read a single
word you see how much of the brain is
engaged the visual system to see the
world the language system to assign it's
a meaning the frontal lobe maybe
thinking about what it would it applies
in the situation I mean just to read a
single word is a majestic interplay of
vision thought and language which covers
a huge percentage of our brain so you
know we need we need all of it to do
really interesting things like reading
and language so we've talked about
change and plasticity in a variety of
ways but a topic I'm getting
increasingly interested in personally
it's plasticity you know past the
twenty-year-old undergraduates okay and
I want to share with you three kind of
things observations auto brain imaging
two of them involved activities that
people can do in the context of
randomized control trials there's so
many claims out there at every level on
every topic but certainly as you get
older about things you should do for
yourself you know
to keep going optimally and many of them
are unfounded scientifically they may or
may not be accurate but they're you know
they're primarily marketed rather than
studied so I'm going to show you
everything I show you I think needs to
put reasonable some reasonable level of
scientific support so one is just an
incidental observation which is this one
of the things I mentioned to you is that
the human brain is organized
predominantly by verbal and nonverbal
knowledge
verbal things in the left language and
nonverbal things in the right hemisphere
like processing faces or music is
primarily right hemisphere and as people
in the brain imaging study looking at
younger and older adults all in good
shape they discovered by
something they could not have seen
without imaging and was not anticipated
or has just happened which is study
after study and this is for different
studies early on whereas younger adults
tended to use or activate one side or
the other for various kinds of memory
tasks the left hemisphere for verbal the
right for spatial like faces older
adults who did pretty well in these
Matassa tended to activate both sides of
the brain
so here's a nice example here's one side
here's both sides younger adults one
side older adults both sides younger
adults mostly this side older adults
both sides so a number of studies like
this and there was a debate in the field
for a little while and there's still
some debate it that goes on but I here's
where I think things down so some people
say ah yet another problem with getting
older not only can't you be an NFL
quarterback you know when you're 75 very
easily but you're leaking information
your specialization is falling apart you
know you've got the wrong part of the
brain getting involved the other version
is oh maybe this is a natural adaptation
that people do when they get out you
know somewhat older that this is a great
strategy to make up for some of the
challenges that go with getting a little
bit older so the way we could answer
that that question was to take the
people in good health who were stronger
or weaker at Memory and ask who shows
using two sides of your brain older
adults are terrific at memory or older
or less terrific at memory that make
sense okay is it a good thing or a bad
thing
and although there's still some debate
in the field about this I think I think
the bulk of the evidence is that it's a
wonderful thing because here's young
people on front of the brain turning on
one side is the work from Alberto cabeza
Duke here's older people whose memory
scores were lower one side of the brain
and here's younger older people whose
memory scores were higher both sides of
the brain so it seems like a natural
adaptation that people as they get older
and maybe some things aren't working as
well cleverly used more of the brain to
accomplish and support their memory
capacities okay because if you just
looked at this not without knowing the
behavior you would think well this looks
like the right pattern to have but maybe
it's not the right pattern to have when
you don't know longer
undergraduate okay sir so this is like
you know this is kind of really
interesting this is natural changes that
are occurring that are successful
adaptations with age so it seems to be
associated with good things physical
exercise there is no area that's better
demonstrated to support both health in
every way and cognition as we get older
than physical exercise I'll show you an
example of this and I'll tell you I'll
say something so here's a study with 120
adults from Erickson Hall where they did
a 60 were assigned to aerobic exercise
and 60 stretching exercise it has to be
aerobic it turns out stretching can be
good strength exercises can be good this
is not to say those are bad things and
then there's but but in terms of
cognition
it's got to be aerobic is it's the
overwhelming message and then it it for
three days a week seven days a week up
to forty minutes a session but not
insane right it's not Arnold
Schwarzenegger sessions it's you know
it's 40 minutes three times a week and
here's here's one example of one thing
they found here's the here's the
beginning of the two groups this is a
group that is stretching this is the
group that and here's what happens not
only does the hippocampus the part of
the brain is important for memory and
get bigger but they sustain that a year
later so these are physical changes in
the structure of the brain that that
show growth physical changes with
exercise so I had a colleague of mine
who went to a National Institute of
Aging that's that part of the Institute
within NIH the study's aging and
somebody got up and gave yet another
demonstration of this the the moderate
consistent a aerobic exercise grows
brain functions and structures and
supports them at all ages and he says
stop let's not do any more research
about this it's so convincing the
problem is how do we get people to
exercise right you know yeah that's the
problem right that's this that's the
neuroscience problem is you know what's
the motivator and you know I can tell
you for myself it wasn't until a couple
years ago that after having read 100
papers I said like now you have to
exercise I'm a little bit almost every
day ok so you know I can't throw stones
on this topic at all but I can't share
with you that there's overwhelming
scientific evidence
that's the one thing that everybody just
about agrees on in very good scientific
ways it's moderately consistent aerobic
physical exercise it's terrific
not only for cardiovascular issues but
also for cognition so let me turn from
one more moment you know towards the
scary topic of Alzheimer's disease which
and we know that involves tangles and
Emma Lloyd plaques in the brain and that
they particularly affect use a healthy
person's hippocampus here's a person
with early-stage Alzheimer's and the the
erosion of the hippocampus due to that
injury nowadays there's a lot of
interest in what's called mild cognitive
impairment and you may have heard about
this an interest in understanding not
the later stages of the disease process
but something much earlier where
intervention is more hopeful and so this
is so mild cognitive impairment is a
label that's given to people who seem to
be in the path towards Alzheimer's
disease about 12% over 85 about 80% of
these convert over the next 10 years but
ten years is a long time I mean is that
you know about 10 to 15% a year and
furthermore in a study where people have
passed away and they looked inside their
brains you can see that the changes in
the hippocampus in patients with mild
cognitive impairment looks already like
Alzheimer's disease by the time people
have mild cognitive impairment
there's been a fair bit of injury in the
very structure that's important for
memory and attacked most aggressively by
Alzheimer's so I was involved in a very
small study so we get this is very
preliminary but it was a random and
study and let me tell you what it was so
we had a only 12 patients six of them
did a cognitive training program on a
computer and six of them also did things
on a computer like listen to the audio
books online newspapers or easy games
ninety minutes a day five days a week
two months so these are people already
with mild cognitive impairment and a
question we were interested in is at
that stage when some things are already
happening is a brain retaining
plasticity that can still be helpful to
a person to sustain a positive mental
life so we have people listen to words
in the scanner these patients with mild
cognitive impairment diagnosis they
would hear a word like table and they
say if it's something they could touch
or word like
love in our sample here's the here's the
effect of the cognitive training so the
scores went up on memory tests for the
people who did the computer-based
cognitive training and it went down in
the control group and in the brain what
we saw as a growth of activation in the
individuals who underwent the cognitive
training program in the hippocampus the
left hippocampus for the verbal tasks so
these are all so even when people are
moving into the beginnings of the
disease process there's still brain
plasticity they can still make a
difference in a person's life and
although everybody who studies
Alzheimer's disease you know dreams of
something that will rescue people from
that path another important thing is to
make people's life better quality for
longer time periods that's a significant
thing and so this plasticity in their
brains for physical exercise or
cognitive activity you know something
that gives us all hope to make our lives
better or people we care about all right
from that somewhat sober topic let me
let me uh let me make you feel even
worse about your memory okay our enemy
to this I use it I teach introductory
and one of the great joys I have here is
I teach introductory psychology to about
300 MIT students every spring and this
this works for all of them they're all
you know eighteen to twenty-two so okay
very so here's what I asked them um I
asked them how many times in their lives
so they think they've seen a penny and
some of you have seen this probably in
some context that you have seen a penny
okay how many times so you could so with
the students I say well let's pretend
there are average age 20 with the
undergraduates and let's pretend they
handled three pennies a day since age
five let's pretend we won't count one
two five okay one two four I don't know
that's that's an estimate right yeah so
by the time
that's 365 days a year 15 years by the
time they're you know in the middle of
MIT as an undergraduate
so that would come out to about sixteen
thousand three hundred eighty exposures
okay to a penny um and if you're so so
if you're uh you know something like
sixty that'd be about four times that so
you know that'd be you know you're
approaching a hundred thousand okay now
almost all of us even if
modest and about our abilities and so on
would think with a hundred thousand
practices we get something kind of right
okay okay all right so let's see which
way does it which way does Lincoln face
what's the bub you said what's below
ascend to the left or to the right okay
alright and then we could agree you know
fifty thousand a hundred thousand it's
stunning right do you have so this is
this is a demonstration that's used to
show to people that it doesn't matter
how often we hear or see something what
matters is how important it is to us was
okay that little brown coin that's all
we need to know it's a penny we don't
need to know which way Lincoln's face it
right okay it's not what you hear and
what you see is what matters that your
brain makes a memory and that's really
clear and vivid and you can use and so
here's multiple choice now I every year
when I present this I have to look up my
notes which is the correct answer I said
I think correct answers a okay so it
looks like kind of like this okay and
here's various drawings from
undergraduates tryna who we creates you
know but you know in yourself you know
yeah okay so turns out I mean there's
many reasons we remember some things
compared to others but we have one
structure in our brain called the
amygdala that sits right in front of the
hippocampus whose job is to remember
things that are especially important and
the way we know they're important is
because we're aroused okay like
something scary something delightful
something really you know that when your
heart is pounding and you're and this
way because something big is an
interesting wonderful or terrible is
happening the amygdala that sits just in
from the hippocampus it's well agreed
upon in neuroscience and lots of animal
work and human work as well that its
primary job used to say this situation
is really important because it's
wonderful or terrible or delightful and
I'll remember it for you know many of
yours okay
not the penny but the things that matter
it's amazing that we have the structure
whose job basically is just to do that
but it makes a lot of sense because we
can't remember everything so we want to
remember what's important and an example
of how if you don't have an amygdala you
don't remember what's important is this
picture this is a rat whose amygdala has
receptive and this amygdala had this rat
has forgotten that if it hangs near a
cat it's gonna be okay
all right and he's really important for
a rat to remember that so so this cat is
a you know look is glassy-eyed because
they have to give it some sedation so it
doesn't immediately eat the rat but I
can tell you you know in these
experiments this is all the way back to
thank said you know rats will not
explore whether a breathing
weird-looking cat is really you know
what its situation is if they see a cat
they go okay it's only the ones with the
amygdala lesions who will go play with
that living cat and all right so so the
amygdala it's a terribly important for
especially for things that we fear and
that's terribly important because what
we fear is important for survival right
you know what's really dangerous you
know we must remember for survival
purposes so the last theme I want to
touch on ends up at did me a go but let
me start with something else so this is
work so so in aging there's lots of
aging research that emphasizes you know
difficulties as we get older like loss
of memory learning new things gets
harder on average even even in a healthy
successful aging and so so it was kind
of a surprise on average and there's
everybody's different but on average and
big averages that when people do its
questionnaires to young adults and
middle aged and elderly adults who
reports themselves as happiest in almost
every study it's older adults okay by
self-report they're happiest right so
satisfied with life you know here's
eight eighteen to forty years 53 or
sixty percent satisfied with standard of
living younger people younger way up to
you know forty percent to 62
frequency of depression is higher in
younger people so by every measure and
it continues to this day people just
seem happier on average when they're
older and that an idea about that has
been something like this from Laura
Carstensen and others that at different
times in our lives different things
matter to us and again this is huge
generalizations but I feel like there's
something true about this and you know
you'll have your own
maybe you'll comment on it that were my
in adolescence and early adulthood we're
very much information seekers you know
we're very much let's go do adventures
let's try jobs let's do interning let's
try things you know maybe I'll like it
maybe I won't but I'll learn something
about myself and about the world from
that you know if it doesn't what's the
price if it doesn't kill me makes me
stronger that kind of thing but that's
that the exploration of adolescence and
young adulthood and then at some time in
our lives
we're not as interested in seeking out
information in a general way but we're
much more interested in sort of seeking
a place where we're happy now this is a
huge generalization but this is an idea
and maybe a little less information
information seeking and so there's an
idea that as we get a little bit older
our motivations and goals are set by
temporal context and as we perceive this
time is limited only tell you the
experience on this length you know just
I mean you know we're not at the very
beginning of the reliance that we sort
of shift our focus from information
acquisition to ammo to regulating
ourselves in a way that makes us happy
and what people are found in study after
study is that as you test older adults
and their 70s pretend compared to
college undergraduates as a typical
study that there's much more focus on
positive things than negative things so
let me show an experiment that supports
that so here's a study where we showed
healthy young adults and healthy older
adults pictures that were positive like
a rabbit or negative like a cemetery or
neutral like a filing cabinet yeah and
then we tested their memory afterwards
and we looked in their brains as they
viewed these scenes so here's the memory
of younger these were about 20 year old
about 70 year old an average positive
pictures they saw negative pictures they
saw in neutral
well everybody remembers the neutral
pictures the least is kind of like the
penny you know the filing cabinet okay
but look at the proportion of recall for
the for the younger people they remember
both the positive and negative scenes
they saw equaling and for the older
individuals much better memory for the
positive information
right so people said okay this and
there's many experiments to support this
and I can tell you if you have questions
that that on average older individuals
you know focus on the positive and years
and years ago I remember people saying
well as we get older and I feel like
this in myself a tiny bit but you know
we get wiser but that's been hard for
experiments to show right because we
don't have we don't have an official
wisdom experiment right you know we get
we can do a memory list very easily in
the laboratory it's very hard to decide
you know here's a test of wisdom right
that would be a good test you'd have to
be super wise to have the right wisdom
test right so um so but there's a
feeling that may be a wise thing and
this is reasonable this to be a happy
person
no no no I'm realistically fatally
unrealistically a happy person not that
that Mouse you know going for the for
the cat but but to look at the positive
things of life and dwell on those and
not dwell on the negative thing and so
you know is this a picture of emotional
wisdom that's acquired you know through
age and experience now some people have
said oh you know um you know that you
can say that but really it's all just
pretending and whatever it is and so let
me show you this experiment so we show
these kinds of people these same
individuals we show that we measure
their brains while they're viewing the
20 year olds and the 17 year olds while
they're viewing these scenes and we
looked in the amygdala the structure
that we know is important for pushing
emotional memories into long-term memory
and here's what we saw so let me start
with the younger people here's the
activity in that part of the brain that
forms emotional memories for positive
and negative pictures looks pretty much
the same and here's neutrals doesn't
care about the neutrals okay as they're
viewing these pictures look at the seven
year olds okay huge engagement for the
positive information non engagement for
the negative so it's not this a story
that we tell afterwards it's the moment
that picture is shown the parts of the
brain that we know are dedicated to
forming long-term memories are focusing
on positive information in a typical
seven year old individual and are sort
of equally positive and negative
20 year olds so you know we all think
that it's good idea I mean we have to
deal with negative things but the more
we can focus on the positive the happier
we can be and so so here's
neurobiological evidence for a sort of
adaptation or change in the brain it's a
very positive thing for the lifespan so
I try to take you in a kind of fast tour
through different things we're going
from everywhere from children to to to
older adults about the powers of the
brain and how it has you know risks or
fragility or but in hand it has great
powers in a sense to heal itself through
exercise through education through
cognitive activity through regulation to
look for the positive through
discovering using both sides Ebor brain
can be a useful tool it has lots of
Secrets that it can use to make changes
that are extremely positive sort of at
every moment of our life thank you very
much yeah oh I have not that
fantastically interesting
yes so our group and several other
groups are working with children with
autism I wish I could tell you that
there's been a breakthrough on that you
know there has not scientifically I'm
gonna say you know there are I think the
studies that will be fantastically
valuable are those that are now looking
at infants born to families a genetic
risk for autism and tracking them from
the moment they're born for the next few
years and by age three now most people
can make the diagnosis and if they could
intervene again it's six months in some
way you know you'd be at a medication or
even behavioral intervention so you know
I don't think anybody in this building
is doing those studies we're looking at
older individuals and autism has been at
the level of cognitive neuroscience
extremely challenging to make progress
and and I think the reason it's
extremely challenging is there's a
slogan from a neurologist as a
specialist in the area that she says
that you know if you've met one child
with autism even that one child with
autism and there's such fantastic
diversity that I think that that's our
problem is you know yet we we don't know
how to deal yet with that diversity so
we take the average of twenty kids but
they're really twenty different stories
and the genetics are like that too that
you know when they find a risk gene
that's associated with it with autism
those typically associated with a half
of one percent of the people of
diagnosis so so we're working on it and
many levels there's a fantastic efforts
in autism and in fact based on animal
work here there's two clinical trials of
children with severe II specific forms
of autism on one's called Rhett syndrome
that are being tried right now so
there's clinical trials of medication
treatments based on animal work for very
specific forms of autism but I wish I
could there's a lot of work on in this
building and our lab too with humans but
but the breakthroughs have not I just
don't feel like we've had the big
breakthroughs that we you know we will
have and need to have yeah
so so I have not we're involved in one
file to tell you where to about this
weren't well done one project with
soldiers with PTSD so we really have a
project in collaboration with Fort Hood
in Texas which is the largest Army
Hospital looking at two different kinds
of treatments being offer behavioral
treatments to see whether soldiers with
mild traumatic brain injury from these
explosions and so often happen occur
there and or PTSD from the war whether
these can help them sort of recover more
effectively or quickly but that's just a
beginning
clinical study professor Gabriela will
be with us at lunch to question so so on
what though I'm brains yes so so so I
believe that the here's probably is the
case that that um you know 95 percent or
more of individuals have language on
their left probably a hundred percent of
right-handers and probably 85 percent of
left-handers also have language on the
left so it doesn't flip over in the vast
majority the cases might as that okay
so some patients with a typical
developmental histories like pediatric
epilepsy so that some things happen very
early in their brain with switch sides
but quite surprisingly the vast majority
of left-handers don't flip their brains
they also have language in the left
hemisphere maybe not as completely quite
but but essentially so handedness you
could think it flip over right like I
use my right hand language here
somebody's as a left hand language here
it's almost always in the left
hemisphere and a person of reasonable
good health
yeah making conscious associations with
other people don't need to do this
information yeah yeah the answer is yes
that uh you know being a little bit more
attentive to information you want to
remember that helps at every age and
disproportion it helps extra when you
want to you know it with every passing
decade yes an informant that we know the
strongest form is a memory you know are
deliberate associative strategies so yes
yes
you're absolutely right